parce que notre ville se transforme
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces maillots yprema votre
partenaire pour un développement durable
bonjour et bienvenue dans équilibre le
magazine de l'environnement et du
développement durable
au sommaire de ce numéro jusqu'au 12
décembre la communauté d'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines organise de
nombreux rendez vous autour de la
question du climat
sandrine le flohic responsable de
l'atelier des sciences nous a reçus pour
nous présenter le programme de valérie
masson delmotte et directeur de
recherche au commissariat à l'énergie
atomique et paléoclimatologue elle
étudie notamment les glaces de
l'antarctique pour comprendre la vitesse
des changements climatiques passés nous
l'avons rencontré une crèche trappistes
développe des activités de produits
naturels et multiplie les éco-gestes
nous nous y sommes rendus
vous entendez sans doute beaucoup parlé
de la coop 21 c'est cette grande
conférence internationale sur les
changements climatiques qui doit débuter
à paris le 30 novembre prochain
à cette occasion les initiatives et
manifestations se multiplient à l'heure
où nous enregistrons cette émission nous
sommes au lendemain des attentats qui
ont coûté la vie à 129 personnes à paris
et le maintien de toutes les
manifestations n'est pas encore assurée
malgré tout nous nous trouvons à
l'atelier des sciences de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines avec sangle le
flohic responsable de la mission bonjour
le chemin nous allons nous intéresser à
la programmation particulière du climat
en question alors vous avez préparé
cette manifestation et que différents
acteurs du territoire notamment le
latmos qui est le laboratoire
atmosphères milieux observations
spatiales de l'université versailles
saint quentin
l'idée c'est de faire découvrir aux
saint quentinois tous les acteurs du
territoire
alors peut-être pas tous parce que je
pense qu'on ne connaîtra pas tous
on n'a pas eu l'occasion de travailler
notamment à valoriser les initiatives
salaires la recherche qui peut être fait
dans les entreprises privées qui bien
sûr aussi que contribuer à réfléchir et
apporter des solutions pour résoudre les
questions liées au climat mais c'est
vrai que il nous semblait essentiel de
travailler avec l'observatoire de
versailles-saint-quentin dont vous avez
cité le latmos y aussi le siarc et puis
le lsc eux comme deux autres il ya des
autres laboratoires clé aussi et il y
avait aussi météo france qui se trouvait
sur notre territoire donc je dirais
qu'il ya peut-être un peu là donc c'est
vrai que pour nous ça me semblait
évident qu'il fallait proposer aux saint
quentinois
un rebond finalement et un éclairage sur
les problématiques thématiques c'est
aussi le moyen de faire découvrir que
chez nous aussi il ya des spécialistes
il a intégré dans cette question là oui
voilà donc gretzky rex qui est
intéressant c'est qu'en plus les
laboratoires et météo france vont avoir
des approches différentes et
certainement complémentaires pour
justement arriver à travailler sur le
climat c'est à dire que la question
climatique
elle est intéressante parce qu'elle
permet de mettre en lumière la manière
dont le travail des scientifiques peut
poser question la société et la manière
après dans des politiques peuvent s'en
saisir voilà se saisir de la 2d
recherche de données pour ensuite après
proposer les solutions légales fusion
des choix voilà ma pensée la question
voilà la question du climat vous l'avez
dit c'est étudié par des spécialistes
c'est pas toujours facile à comprendre
l'intérêt sur ce mois ci c'est la
vulgarisation aussi exactement
c'est vrai qu'il y aurait plein de
manières de parler du sujet du climat
c'est un sujet qui dans le domaine
scientifique mais peut-être le meilleur
exemple de la clope complexité c'était
vraiment indépendant très sont très
nombreuses les modèles sont difficiles à
comprendre tant il ya deux paramètres
qui rentrent en ligne de compte
et c'est vrai que donc nous dans notre
programmation
on a essayé d'apporter des éclairages
qui se veulent justement des éclairages
pour arriver à avoir une meilleure idée
des choses peut-être aussi pour ne pas
avoir trop d'à priori d'idées préconçues
et pour se rendre compte de l'importance
à la fois de l'action individuelle de
l'action collective et puis de voilà des
différents impacts aussi de la diversité
en fait des problématiques et ce à
travers des choses qui sont très
concrètes donc des donc dans des
ateliers on est sur des choses très
pratique sur l'effet de serre
si on arrivait à reconstituer la fin ne
pas pourvoir
ce fut exactement des choses très
content très concrète apprennent sur des
entrées plus artistique quand on assiste
à un spectacle en famille
c'est des choses sur lesquelles les
parents peuvent rebondir ces évocations
pour comprendre l'actualité est par
contre c'est vrai que dès qu'on est des
expositions comme ici où le contenu est
plus riche et puissant lors de leurs
deux cafés des sciences on est par
contre là ce moment là sur des contenus
qui vont être plus pointu donc sur
l'ozone sur par exemple le travail
spécifique de météo france ou sur
justement le rôle des chercheurs d'un
climat par rapport aux décisions
d'aujourd'hui
donc c'est adapté aux enfants et aux
adultes en fonction des ateliers voilà
exactement c'est vraiment enfin nous on
a essayé pour cette programmation dans
ce sens là pour çà répondre à tout le
monde
des animations déjà eu lieu c'est le cas
du serious game qui s'est jouée le 7
novembre dernier à la médiathèque du
petit canal sephora namani et vivent une
sterne bergé ils y ont participé
depuis plus d'un siècle nous utilisons
les ressources énergétiques sans se
préoccuper de leur quantité direction
l'année 2020 nous pourrions être dans
une impasse
la mission de ces enfants remonter le
temps là il s'agit d'aider le maire à
choisir une source d'énergie durable
tout à l'heure on a parlé d énergie on a
dit qu'elle pouvait être fossile donc
est ce que les énergies fossiles sont
durables non d'accord mais aussi suspect
serious game est particulièrement
focalisée autour des enjeux des
problématiques autour de l'énergie donc
lié à ce pillage de l'énergie des
énergies fossiles et énergies
renouvelables de la sobriété énergétique
et de l'efficacité énergétique
accompagné de trois conseillers
environnemental social et économique
ces jeunes ont dû notamment et des
benjamins organiser ses vacances ou
olivier à reconstruire un village on a
c'est une ville
enfin un arrêt 5 enfin on a renouvelé la
ville on a amélioré on a mis des
panneaux solaires pour les pour les
connexions pour l'énergie économiser
l'électricité parce que j'ai c'est que
des fois quand ce genre de machin j'ai
soudain ali mais eux sont parvenus à
rendre la terre plus durable et vivable
si vous voulez vous aussi tenter de
protéger la planète
le serious game peut se jouer en ligne
le clip en question c'est du 12 novembre
au 12 décembre quatorze sites de
l'agglomération sont concernés le climat
c'est une question importante
oui le climat c'est vraiment une
question essentielle surtout aujourd'hui
parce que là on vraiment en fait tous
les tous les paramètres montre bien
qu'il ya une situation d'urgence d'
alerte à très court terme
en fait on est vraiment là dans les 20
ans 30 ans à venir dans des dents des
décisions importantes à prendre pour les
générations futures pour nos enfants
merci sandrine le fleuve pour toutes ces
explications si vous souhaitez apprendre
et connaître toutes les problématiques
du climat le site internet de la télé
des sciences vous donne toute la
programmation
vous venez de l'entendre avec notre
invité la question du climat est très
importante sur 51 évident notamment à
travers ces chercheurs on a parlé du
latmos mais de nombreux autres
laboratoires sont concernés le lsc eux
le laboratoire des sciences du climat et
de l'environnement présent sur le
plateau de saclay dans l'essonne est une
unité mixte du cea du cnrs et de l'uvm
ce qu 250 personnes y travaillent dont
valérie masson delmotte
elle est directrice de recherche et
paléo climatologue nous l'avons
rencontré à l'occasion d'une visite de
thierry blondeau secrétaire d'état à
l'enseignement supérieur et à la
recherche
je m'intéresse à à reconstituer
l'ampleur et la vitesse des changements
climatiques passés donc on n'a pas des
thermomètres sur une durée infinie
par exemple en antarctique on n'a que
cinquante ans au mieux de mesures
directes et non pour connaître comment
le climat a varié après on va utiliser
la neige qui s'est déposé année après
année et en étudiant cette neige les
molécules d'eau qui la constituent et
l'abondance des molécules un petit peu
plus lourdes aux un petit peu plus
légère on peut estimer les variations de
températures au cours du temps vous
voyez des échantillons de carottes de
glace de l'antarctique par exemple ici
donc qui viennent du dôme c'est
l'endroit où on a huit cent mille ans
d'archivés du climat enregistré dans ce
type d'échantillon quand on est un
échantillon qui peu profonds mais qui a
déjà quelques milliers d'années
en fait les sciences du climat ça
mobilise l'étude des climats passés des
observations actuelles et une
représentation du climat de manière
virtuelle à l'aide de modèles numériques
c'est parce qu'en fait on ne peut pas
faire en laboratoire une maquette du
climat de la terre l'océan l'atmosphère
la végétation les glaces
le vivant qui interagit avec ça on peut
pas le faire en laboratoire lauren
original obtient un diplôme d'ingénieur
en 1993 de l'école centrale paris
valérie masson-delmotte choisi de se
former par la recherche et passent une
thèse financé par le cea le commissariat
à l'énergie atomique qu'elle intègre
comme chercheur en 1996 de 1998 à 2008
elle est responsable de l'équipe
glaciaux glace et continent climat et
isotopes stables
c'est quelque chose qui m'avait
interpellé quand j'étais lycéenne à
partir de lectures sur l'actualité
scientifique je peux pas vraiment
expliquer pourquoi peut-être parce que
je n'ai bien rêver en verre dans les
nuages en octobre dernier valérie masson
delmotte est élue présidente du groupe
de travail 1 du giec le groupement
d'experts intergouvernemental sur
l'évolution du climat
ce groupe est chargé d'étudier et
d'estimé scientifiquement les causes et
les évolutions du changement climatique
le gic est composé de 34 nombre l'europe
dispose de huit sièges
le gicl qui fait le point sur l'état des
connaissances en particulier sur la
physique du climat a toujours eu un an
une attention portée à ce qu'on apprend
des climats passés donc moi j'avais
contribué au quatrième rapport dans le
chapitre sur les climats passés au
cinquième rapport
j'ai coordonné avec un col également un
chapitre dédié à la compréhension des
variations climatiques passées et puis
donc j'ai été retenu pour piloter ce la
production du sixième rapport donc entre
maintenant et puis 2021-2022 le 12
novembre valérie masson-delmotte animé
une conférence grand public autour des
problématiques du climat et des enjeux
de la com 21 en présence notamment de
jean jouzel climatologue et glaciologue
experts du giec depuis 1994 en fait on
est payé par par de l'argent public par
les impôts des gens dont je pense que
c'est vraiment notre mission aussi que
nos connaissances à ne reste pas dans
des revues ultra spécialisés qui ne sont
lus que par par quelques poignées de
chercheurs mais qu'elle rentre aussi au
petit à petit dans une sorte de culture
générale
de plus en plus d'établissements
scolaires saint quentinois s'engage dans
une démarche écologique ou de
développement durable et cela concerne
même les établissements d'accueil des
tout-petits
c'est le cas de la crèche les acrobates
situé dans la zone d'activité de pi
salle où l'établissement espère d'ici
l'année 2016 obtenir le label eco nos
crèches un reportage réalisé avec
patrick jacques de dixmude
alors les enfants dont je m'habille
convenez avec moi pour l activité
d'accord alors vous allez toucher en
sable vous pouvez choisir ce nouveau les
bons joueurs avaient les assiettes et
mon cher l'atelier de ce matin pour ses
enfants de 18 à 24 mois c'est le sable
magique de la farine de l'huile du sel
et quelques épices que j'aimais tant
qu'on est dedans on essaie de d'utiliser
le plus tôt possible produits naturels
déjà c'est tellement mieux pour la
sécurité des enfants les enfants ils
apprennent beaucoup par par le goût par
la bouche et là on sait que ces gouttes
voir s'il n'y a pas de problème quand je
vais t'aider
j'ajoute un peu des pistes à mouscane la
cannelle pour aussi faire pour
contribuer au développement de sens de
l'odorat à farid le sable le toucher
produits naturels pour les activités des
enfants alimentation bio lors des
goûters lumières éteintes à la sortie
d'une pièce ou encore produits
d'entretien préparer chaque semaine
l'équipe composée de 22 personnes
adoptées les éco-gestes accompagnés par
les tout-petits
je pense qu a pas d'âge pour commencer à
les éduquer et
pour cela devienne pour eux naturel de
pas gaspiller l'eau quand on se lave les
mains de pas tiré trois fois la chasse
d'eau d'apprendre petit à petit mais ils
apprennent donc d'éteindre les lumières
j'ai découvert jeu la balle est que le
crash que je connaissais pas et je suis
ravie je suis ravi parce que c'est pour
moi c'est vraiment une chose qu'on
puisse participer que crache attitude
nous donne les moyens de mettre en place
à ces déformations cc du camp la crèche
vise le label pour l'année 2016 ce label
est l'idée d'une association du même nom
il est décerné aux crèches qui postulent
sur un dossier anonyme présenté à un
comité de diagnostic espacées de trois
ans au maximum sont réalisés avant de
décerner le label près de 180 crèches
sont aujourd'hui labellisé en france
elle a comparé long bec dieu les deux
diagnostics qui permet le prince ou du
label
il faut que la crise ait fait des
problèmes dans trois des huit grands
thèmes qui sont prêtés dans la démarche
écolo crêpes qui sont le bâtiment l'eau
l'énergie les baissiers l'alimentation
les produits d'entretien l'entretien des
locaux l'hygiène et les activités et
jeux l'équipe espère être labellisé
durant l'année 2016 le deuxième audit
est en train d'être mis en place pour
évaluer son évolution
verdict dans quelques mois
en raison des événements survenus à
paris l'organisation de certaines
manifestations n'est pas assurée si des
activités vous intéresse n'hésitez pas à
vous renseigner auprès des organisateurs
équilibre c'est terminé je vous donne
rendez vous le mois prochain et d'ici là
pensent à faire un geste pour
l'environnement